thank you
got a story this is FYI the show where
you get to report on the issues you care
about I'm here at the Lee Valley
Athletic Center to investigate why so
many girls my age seem to drop out of
sports
and would you live in a city that floats
on water we head to New York to see how
Americans plan to adapt to rising sea
levels
foreign
so as always we have loads of info for
you to help us or get a better
understanding of the news like what's
all the fuss about Prince Harry's book
and how far should the protest of the
climate change go more later and we have
your stories too let's start off with a
report from Isabel an FYI viewer who
wants to kick-start a more open chat
about puberty and she wants boys to
listen up too
I'm a runner I train every week as well
as compete and I hope to keep doing
sports for the rest of my life
but each year that I grow older I
noticed there are less and less girls
training in my age groups
did you know more than half of girls
quit their favorite sport by the time
they finish school but why is this I've
done some digging and it's not an easy
answer we need to talk about puberty
our bodies go for a massive change as we
start to become an adult
it's called puberty
and of course when your body is changing
so much you become self-conscious
some Studies have found that a lot of us
fear being judged and bullied and we
lose confidence in how we feel and look
going through puberty is very difficult
for a girl who can experience weight
gain body hair growth and other bodily
changes which can make us feel quite
self-conscious when wearing sports
clothes and doing an activity
and periods this can be a difficult
change for girls
cramps bloating tiredness and it no one
wants to talk about the subject but what
would happen if we were more open about
puberty and periods
I spoke to some of my friends who are
still training in sports and they are
well up for talking openly about a
subject most shy away from so what have
been some challenges that you guys have
faced as a teenage girl in sports period
has been like a bad one for me but yeah
I think everyone goes through that
because yeah when you have a cramp and
it's a competition day it's always like
that's so stressful and like sometimes
you have to miss training because you've
got a bad cramp or you're feeling too
tired or you've got a headache it's hard
to tell coaches especially when most of
them are male and it's hard for the male
coaches to understand because obviously
they don't go for it themselves but if
we could make them more aware I don't
know how yeah maybe like in you know
like coaching courses that they do maybe
like put like a bit of section in that
where it's like how to deal with like
teenage girls on their periods or like
Teenage struggles that we just face in
general all the coaches I have a male so
it's like much harder to talk to them
about that kind of things we do need
help with it it's not like we can just
face it by ourselves and I think it's a
reason a lot of girls drop out I mean
apart from periods what other barriers
have you I mean it's actually kind of
like body image issues because you know
especially because not just in athletics
like you know swimming like you're
wearing shorts and like crop tops and
stuff so you can be like self-conscious
a lot like you know about body hair and
things like that I'm really conscious
about that because every time before a
race I'm always like do I have any hair
on my legs like do I need to shave do
you think it'd be a good idea if um like
in the P like education system that they
introduced like a section where um
that's all that girls think about when
boys can just like literally look like
anything and another like part of
puberty is like all the hormones can
kind of like overwhelm me of all the
emotions and the mood swings and things
like that what support do you wish you
had at school we should be taught about
the emotional side of puberty as well as
the physical changes like the social
side and kind of how it sort of impacts
on your self-esteem everyone needs to be
taught about it not just our age or like
not just adults like even boys our age
needs to be taught about it so they
understand that it's a thing that we all
go through people should be more open
about these kind of things it's just
what happens to you it is a part of life
and it shouldn't be seen as something
you know that's inappropriate it's clear
not enough is being done to support us
as we get older we need to bust a myth
that teenage girls are dropping out just
because we're not interested I want to
see a future where we can talk openly
about puberty and never feel alone with
it I want to see a future where girls
can take part in sports without the fear
of being judged I want to see a future
where we can feel confident about how we
look no matter what changes we are going
through
thanks Isabel well we all know that
puberty is a really important subject
and there are loads of questions but
sometimes we're just too embarrassed to
ask so we called in an expert
fyi's Maya took up the challenge with
her questions for Dr Alex George the
government's youth Ambassador for mental
health
hi Dr Alex how are you I'm very well
thank you so for those of us who don't
know what is puberty and when does it
start puberty put simply as the change
as we go from being a child to being an
adult generally around eight years old
who's at the age of what 16 or 17 we go
through changes in our body and our
hormones change even our minds change as
well as we mature this is different
between boys and girls so what does it
mean for us girls you know what kind of
things happen to our bodies so in girls
breast develop we grow hair in different
places like for example under the
armpits and in the pubic regions and
also the the brain basically tells the
ovaries to start releasing eggs and
really what we're talking about is that
maturation process to allow you to
potentially be a mother so the first
period that a girl experiences can be
anywhere as young as eight years old and
when that happens that process can be
quite new or uncomfortable talking about
periods is a bit of a taboo subject how
can we change that I think it's
education not just for girls but for
boys as well so in the school place that
can be having policies that make
um you know for example Sport AS
inclusive as as possible making sure
we're actually teaching effectively
about puberty at school and I think the
schools and also why the society saying
it's okay to have questions and it's
okay to feel you know worried about this
it's okay to come forward and need help
so really we just have to normalize it
yeah it's just about making the
conversation normally
we've contacted the government to see
what they're doing to help girls stay in
sport they said they're investing in
lots of projects across the country to
give girls better access to physical
activities both in and out of school and
they've issued guidance for schools on
how they can support girls with their
periods
now you've probably seen the role the
royal family in the
evening but not for the reasons they
would like to be Prince Harry has
released a story about his personal life
an autobiography but why has it caused
so much controversy vanity Fair's Royal
correspondent and author Katie Nichol
joins us now to find out more hi Katie
thank you for joining us so what does
Prince Harry talk about in his book well
I think the big question is what story
doesn't Prince Harry talk about he talks
about the difficulty of growing up in
his older brother Prince William's
Shadow Prince William's always been the
heir to the throne and Prince Harry's
always been known as the spirit he also
explores his relationship with his
father and his relationship with Meghan
Markle they felt that they didn't have
the support of the royal family and that
they really had no choice but to start a
new life in America so Katie this is on
top of lots of TV interviews Royals
don't usually talk openly about private
matters so why Prince Harry he says so
many other people have told his story
but he wants to tell his story now and I
think that's what spare is all about for
him so what have the reactions been to
the book the reactions have been pretty
mixed but a lot of people also feel that
he's revealed too much that really
private details of conversations that he
has had with his father and with his
brother should really have stayed behind
the palace doors
some good news the government announced
that they will be banning the use of
single-use plastic items in England such
as plastic plates Cutlery and
polystyrene trays that's great news for
the environment the making of plastic
contributes to climate change and a lot
of plastic waste ends up in our oceans
killing Wildlife some countries aren't
just looking at slow and down climate
change they're also planning on living
with it here's Lila in New York with a
report on how the USA could adapt to
rising sea levels
you might recognize this place from the
Spider-Man movies it's probably the most
famous city in the world welcome to my
home New York
foreign
New York's got a problem a really big
problem as our planet's climate changes
the ice caps are melting and there are
more and more storms
and because New York is surrounded by
water it means that flooding is becoming
more and more common just take a look at
this this is not a disaster movie it's
real life Hurricane Sandy in 2012 and
hurricane Ida in 2021 caused immense
damage many people lost their lives
for my family it was a really scary time
I remember one night we were watching TV
and we just heard this gushing noise
from downstairs we went down and there
was like a waterfall pouring through my
window I think at one point the water
was up to like here
some New York residents are now asking
themselves how much longer they can go
on living here as the climate becomes
more and more extreme and the sea level
continues to rise
one possible solution is to try and hold
back the waves with the sea wall and
that's exactly what they're doing here
the city is spending billions of pounds
on flood defenses I'm meeting Thomas one
of the leading Engineers so Lila
following superstorm Sandy what we came
up with is a sea wall that runs all
around the southern tip of Manhattan
it's about 10 miles long we looked at it
and we thought about wave action and the
potential for water still splashing over
the wall which is why we're coming up to
an elevation which is about nine feet
higher than where we're standing right
now
so here's the thing flood defenses are
great but some people think they're just
a sticking plaster and eventually a bit
like with my sand castle the rising sea
levels will do their damage
so do we need a more radical solution to
save our coastal cities and ultimately
to save Humanity
well how about this an incredible vision
of the future like something out of a
movie Welcome to the world's first
floating city
so this is just a computer-generated
animation showing what it might look
like but believe it or not a city like
this could soon become a reality I'm
meeting the chief engineer from a
company called oceanx which is hoping to
build the world's first floating city in
South Korea the advantage of 14 seating
is we can move up and down with the ways
and with the tides and the feather is
floating it's also helpful because it
will accommodate the sea water level
rising but how can you make a city float
won't like the buildings and everything
be just way too heavy well it follows a
certain physical principle which is the
one that is used by boats right they are
very heavy but they still float so is
this an exception that we just can't
beat climate change we're gonna have to
live with it I believe what we're doing
right now here is trying to find the
solutions to a problem that is actually
becoming real there are a lot of Nations
right now where their population has
been displaced they're becoming climate
refugees and so if it's going to be
stopped we have potential Solutions and
this is one of the solution and we're
going to pursue with them
so maybe we're going to need a new New
York a city that floats like a boat how
crazy is that
nice report Lila when it comes to
climate change one thing we all want is
to have our voices heard by the
politicians in charge but protest groups
like Extinction Rebellion have been
criticized for stopping traffic
vandalizing buildings and statues to get
the message across Extinction Rebellion
have said they will not be using
disruptive protests for now admitting it
had little effect on getting their
message across but there are other
groups that just stop oil they also use
disruptive tactics and they say they
will not stop until the government
promises to end you all your own gas
Productions the very fuels that lead to
climate change
but are there methods of protesting
Justified time for you to get your shout
on this we went to Plymouth home of the
Tamar Bridge connecting Devon to
Cornwall we're going to hear from an FYI
News Club at devonport High School
do you think Art's a valid Target for
climate protesters I think it's only
valid because the protesters are
protesting something they find important
I don't think it is they want the public
to listen to them so they're making big
statements like throwing super paintings
so people will notice them because they
said they knew that the glass was there
and they weren't really intending to
damage the painting more just get people
to notice the way they're doing it is
the wrong way yeah they are protesting
about the climate but the where they're
going at it is bad I've also heard about
them stopping the traffic as a protest
and it's just a really horrible thing to
do overall I disagree with people
distracting traffic because they're
walking in the road to stop people using
like Diesel and petrol but what they're
doing is slowing traffic down so they're
making people burn more petrol and
Diesel they're making matters worse by
protesting in the streets and people who
are in those cars there could be
ambulances with like people who are in
critical condition and if it costs some
somebody their life that's definitely
not the best way to catch people's
attention you can do other ways but I
really don't think that disrupting
traffic and destroying things is really
not going to help matters I think we
should be arrested for protesting in a
disruptive way I feel like you need to
be loud but you shouldn't be aggressive
people aren't going to want to support
your campaign if you do it in a harmful
way
climate change is becoming more and more
of a problem so if we don't take care of
it immediately then we're not going to
have a plan anymore
we want to leave you with some more
positive news about the environment this
week scientists announced that the hole
in the earth's ozone layer is on track
to being completely healed by 2040
result the ozone layer is a thin part of
the Earth's atmosphere that absorbs most
of the ultraviolet radiation from the
Sun if the radiation reaches the surface
it can be harmful to humans and other
living things
so back in the 1980s there was an
international agreement to stop using
the harmful chemicals that caused the
hole and it seems to be working see you
next time for more info on the big
stories bye
foreign